as promised we're going to dive straight
back into the world of 3d vectors
i hope that you had some opportunity
within the last
four weeks to remember yes uh
prior to you jumping into the holidays
we sort of introduced this topic right
we built straight off of what we did in
extension 1 vectors in 2d
and we're like well when we lift this
into three dimensions what's different
and what's the same we introduced the
idea of the dot product in extension 1
and then looked at it ever so briefly
at the end of last term so rather than
just jump off and assume
you remember that let's see if we can
collectively put back into our memory
uh number one how to calculate the dot
product and then i'm also going to ask
you
what does that thing mean again so i
wonder if anyone can help me
going back to extension one we can
calculate the dot product
i'll even give you a hand it's really
simple there are two
little products involved when you're
doing the dot product
of a pair of 2d vectors can anyone help
me start
what are the things that we're
multiplying together to work out a
2d dot product yeah go ahead okay
xy x2 plus y2 x1 x2
plus y1 y2 so before i jot down
something
pretty much equivalent to that let's
remember what he's talking about you've
got two vectors
they each have like a horizontal
component they each have a
vertical component so you just kind of
pair them up and then off you go okay
perfect i've called my two vectors that
i'm
dot producting dot multiply
a and b so a way that might be more
relevant to this is rather than x1 x2
i'm going to call them x a
that's the x of the first one and then
the x of the
second one right xb right so there's my
x1 x2 as it were x axb and then if i
just carry that along
i then do the vertical components yes i
guess i would very
creatively call them y a and y b
fantastic
now i wonder if you can remember that
this is not the
only way to compute the dot product
there's another way or this other way
gives you
access to knowing another sort of
tool to use if you can think back to
some of your
trigonometry calvin you want to give it
a go um the
absolute value of a times
b
yeah fantastic so we've got our
magnitudes of each of our
vectors and then we multiply it by the
well sort of canonically we call it
theta it doesn't really matter of course
what you call it c is also fine
this of course importantly is the angle
between
the two a and b vectors now this is
important because you can imagine um
my two vectors could be anywhere right
they could sort of be like
here they are okay depending on their
positions what we do is we say imagine
them
together right we put their tails
together and then we consider this angle
in here
right now this is very important because
if for example
you've got these two vectors and they're
pointing in exactly
the same direction what is theta going
to be equal to
this is zero right so when you go ahead
and work out cos of zero
cos of zero is one so therefore
you're multiplying these things and
they're working in the maximum like same
direction together do you remember that
if i then say oh what if i have a theta
of
pi on two cos of pi on two is
zero so in fact your dot product ends up
being zero
if your two vectors are
perpendicular or a better word in the
context of vectors is
orthogonal right and then one last one
just as a classic example
if we then said okay if our vectors are
heading the opposite direction
right the theta between them will be
pi and cos of pi is
cos of pi is it's negative one
negative one so they're acting in the
most opposite direction
we can right does that make sense so you
get like some
large negative number okay now this is
my segue to remind you
this is how you calculate the dot
product but what does it mean again we
gave you like a bunch of different
metaphors for this
how would you describe it this is the
hard part
this is that moment much like mrs lies
and i get when when we're marking your
papers
and sometimes it's like have i taught
them anything um
what does it mean to say and i was
giving you these sort of vectors to give
you an
illustration of this right it's one way
to think of it is how much of these
how much are these vectors working
together
with each other right are they working
really alongside each other are they
kind of
working like nothing to do with each
other right they're orthogonal are they
working
opposite to each other that's kind of
what this is telling you yeah
wonderful so again we already actually
know this bit but to get your brain in
the same spot
if we were to extend this
two-dimensional result here into
three dimensions well it doesn't take a
huge amount of creativity
what's going to change instead of doing
x a x b plus y a y b
what's going to be change is the wrong
word what's additional to this
there's just yeah there's just the
comment write it with me right we've got
all of the same stuff we had before
x a x b because there's still a
horizontal component
y a y b because there's still a vertical
component but now i've got a
a third dimension right so i'm going to
go z a
z b okay
now at this point i want you to remember
and i'm just going to run out of hands i
should have brought the table back out
to do this
when we go into 3d even though computing
it
in component form requires us to have
this extra dimension
on there when we go and try and do this
you know comparison to the trigonometric
form
i wonder how many of you were surprised
that in fact the result is
like what's the formula in three
dimensions
it's say it again i heard it it's
exactly the same
it's exactly the same uh
magnitude of a magnitude of b and then
cos of the angle between them and the
reason for that is
even when you're in three dimensions and
you've got two vectors off in weird
wonderful directions right
you can always find a single plane
a single plane it just might be a weird
funny orientation
you can always find a single plane that
both of your vectors
will sit on and so for the purposes of
working out like are these guys working
together are they working against each
other
you're going to work out this same thing
it's just like you were in two
dimensions you just kind of have to
rotate
until you see them almost like flat onto
a different plane okay
so that's what the dot product was and
you can just calculate it it's not that
hard and in fact that's
almost what we're about to do but what i
want you to focus on today
is that you can use this thing you can
apply the dot product to solve a couple
of well not a couple of different
problems many different problems
we're just going to do a couple today
though have a look at this heading here
this is
a1 for application one you might be able
to make a guess
at what this application is based on
this
secondary form of the dot product
it's not just the components it's got
this cos theta in it
right so what we can use the dot product
for one of its many uses is to work out
between vectors if you don't already
know
what it is you can work out the angle
between the vectors so this is going to
be our first application
now it's not too hard to think about the
path through this and i'm going to get
you guys to do this now because i think
you don't need too much help to
get on the road if you have a look at
this pair of vectors here a
and b i can very straightforwardly i'm
going to ask you to start it now
in a straightforward fashion i can
compute the dot products this is going
to be a number
at the end right i'm going to match up
my horizontal
components my vertical ones my
deep other ones right i'm going to
multiply each one through i'll just get
a number out
right but according to the fact that i
can use these two different ways of
thinking about the dot product
once you get this number on the left it
equals this thing on the right they're
the same
they're two different perspectives on
the same object right so therefore if
you can work out everything on the left
if you can work out the magnitude of
vector a
and the magnitude of vector b then
the only thing that's left the only
unknown is cos
theta so i'm going to ask you and this
is why i mentioned you're going to need
calculators there
in degrees i wonder if off the basis of
the dot product maybe you're already
you've already computed can you work out
the angle that will be formed
between these two vectors can you have a
go at that um i'll give you guys a
couple minutes i know some people are
still drawing down notes as i was
speaking
have a go and then we'll come back
together
all right so i think hopefully that was
enough
catch up time for those of you who it's
like
okay brain's still warming up because
body is tormenting up all that kind of
thing right
let me walk you through how i've done
this okay
the dot product as i mentioned before is
kind of my doorway into
working out my angles here right or
angle singular okay
what i've done here is on the left hand
side of the right-hand side i've just
computed the dot product twice
just from different formulas as it were
right
so here's me doing the components i hope
you agree that i've done my x's and then
i've done my uh
y's and then my z's as it were and mean
you asked me a good question
before which was that you know this has
been provided in component form can i
write it in column form if that makes it
easier for me and the answer is
just like in complex numbers unless it's
specified you use the form that is most
appropriate to the solving
of the question so if that made you feel
better um that you could say oh i can
see the negative 2 and the 1
and the negative 3 and the negative 2
and the 2 and the 1 lining up
horizontally if that works for you go
for it however
do be mindful sometimes they do specify
every now and then as you saw in your
recent task
we'll sometimes say we want you to use
this form of a complex number and we can
just as easily say
we want you to use this form of a vector
okay didn't specify here so do whatever
you like
i've computed from both sides and once
you do all the substitution
right here's the matching upper
components here's me working out
each of the magnitudes of the vectors
just using pythagoras
okay you end up with something like this
do i get some agreement is that looking
okay right
um of course this part here you might
feel is slightly excessive all of this
could have just been done by your
calculator because that's where you were
going anyway
but i think it is always helpful
especially given the number of
arithmetical errors that were made in
your recent exams
push your brain please don't just let it
atrophy because that's what happens when
you don't use it
make sure you know what you're doing
here what angle did you get i asked for
it in degrees i think
54 you happy with that
cool yeah i was like oh i remembered
something different and then i realized
i didn't round to the
nearest unit i ran into decimals but
that's fine with me
i even didn't provide an accuracy so
that's my fault
happy with that makes sense one of the
wonderful things about this by the way
is unlike say you know when you learn
the sign rule the first time do you
remember that back in like
u10 uh we had to deal with ambiguity the
ambiguous case of the sine rule but the
cosine rule has no such problem
right because when you run through from
zero all through a through to
pi you get what's what i'm looking for
unique values
right you don't have to think oh do i
have the acute version or the obtuse
version
so in fact if you wanted you could have
said right from the outset and the
textbook actually does this right
it says theta is equal to unambiguously
cos inverse of and then it takes your
dot product over here
and then divides through by everything
over here on the right hand side
right so if you wanted it not that i
think it's worth memorizing but what did
i just say
because sorry theta equals
cause why'd i rub that out um
where's my components so i guess i would
just say a
dot b all over what was left on the
right hand side
it's the magnitude of a and the
magnitude of
b and just chuck that in there right um
i think it is vastly superior to
actually
know what you're doing rather than have
another formula in your head
which you could just as easily have
gotten from rearranging that but
you'll see this sometimes so once you
know where it comes from okay